the united nations is celebrating world
refugee day today commemorating the
strength courage and perseverance of
refugees and if you needed a reminder
well the war in ukraine is showing us
once again the horror that people face
when they are forced out of their homes
by conflict or persecution since 1975
the united states has welcomed more than
three million refugees from all over the
world and we asked three of them to
share their stories
[Music]
name is jessie calzado esvonda my name
is kumari reg me my name is george stark
and this is the story of how i became a
refugee
some of the worst fighting in the
endless civil war broke out near the
american embassy i came to the united
states in 1999 due to a 14-year civil
war in liberia my birth country
i was about six years old when we fled
liberia i lost a few family members
mainly my
grandfather and my father i personally
almost got killed during the civil war i
was standing on top of a hill and a
bullet just came and you know passed
right by my ear
[Music]
i was six years old when my family were
forceful we evicted from bhutan the
country's former ruler king jigme sigma
wangchuk imposed tough new citizenship
laws on ethnic nepalis all
people has to practice buddhism and then
speak their language and then wear their
clothing and many families that have
been tortured people were taken from the
community and were beaten at night so we
could hear them crying at night so my
parents and my grandparents were talking
saying that you know i think someone
will come and will be
killed so we need to leave
home right now
in a blink of an eye and no fault of my
own i became a refugee
i came to the u.s when i was seven years
old and this happened in 1995 when we
had the huge
migration of rafter crisis from cuba
coming to america 13 cuban boat people
picked up in the caribbean last week
people who really prefer to just risk
your life and going across the sea than
to spend one more day in like
economically collapsed cuba chaos
erupted they've grabbed me put me in
this raft and i actually became an
accidental refugee
by being placed in this raft it was 16
people and a dog i could never really
fully described
the the intensity of the sea
but then years later i saw a movie
castaway and there was a scene where
it's the water and it's the ocean and
it's and it was thundering
you brought me back to that moment it
was exactly what i experienced
we made our way to ghana where we end up
living in budupurang refugee camp i
spent that 17 years in the refugee camp
after we were rescued we were
transferred to guantanamo bank there was
a lot of many days where you know we
went to bed hungry we used to eat rice
in the morning and rice at night there
was no snacks or
no fruits or anything i've seen so many
little kids dying because of
malnutrition
study island was the first place that we
got resettled i lived in miami for a
little bit and then in tampa florida the
first day when i came to america was the
day that barack obama was inaugurated so
help me god congratulations mr president
i saw
you know on the news everywhere like
obama obama i never forget that day it
took a while to adjust to life in the
united states
i think the biggest challenge was the
first thing was the language the
language barrier
[Music]
and the other was the culture the food
the clothing while the community was
very supportive the children could be
very cruel when we first started school
due to the fact that we had a heavy
accent where we always made fun of
sometimes i was bullied because of my
accent or because i didn't look like
everyone else and
when people found out that i wasn't from
america
children just were not educated and as
children do like they're like well why
aren't you from america that's weird
right we're called different type of
african name they asked me a question
like if i used to walk around naked it
used to really upset me i wish back then
i would have just taken it for myself to
educate people in africa
i do wanted to tell people out there
listen to refugees listen to their
stories and if you could help them
please help them
no one's a refugee by choice a refugee
can be anybody despite some people's
beliefs we're not murderers
we're not
people and women who are trying to steal
your jobs these are all people that
prior to something happening to them
we're just regular day people just like
everyday americans right living their
lives going to school getting married
having fun
but it just takes a moment you know like
the invasion of russia into ukraine for
you to become a refugee i think we saw
that a lot recently in ukraine and a lot
of people are saying oh this is not
something you see in europe this is
something you see in africa it just
tells you that they don't really know
what a refugee is you only listen to
them you will know what they are going
through and
just give them the place to live like us
[Music]
boy and on this world refugee day i
think it's such a good reminder i like
what jesse said no one is a refugee by
choice right there's a famous poem which
has a
wisdom in it and it says that you don't
put your child or your family in a boat
unless the water is somehow safer than
the land that you're stepping off of so
true and it's worth reminding us that as
as you know we have three million
refugees since 1975 but the numbers have
declined in recent years if we put new
limits on who can come
and it's a reminder that they're not
coming by choice right now it's up to us
to remind
our kids our children to embrace them
because we were talking about what you
mean
not to be so mean you know it's the type
of thing that we take so much for
granted those of us who are born and
raised here
the fact that jesse said that the
scene from castaway reminded her what it
took to get here something we should
think about and the country was founded
by people fleeing persecution let's
recall as well you know right about the
only difference is time yeah do you
think it's one of the greatest places to
be but sometimes you need a reminder
what it takes to get here yep very nice
job to you chris z well done chris
zoetowski i know i screwed it up we'll
call him chrissy and to you the editor
why we use the chris z i know
zawatowski
is that right zawatowski
zawastowski
that was towsky because you know his
parents are watching and i don't want to
screw up his name on national tv chris z
bravo daniel drake those pieces are very
hard to do where there is no track where
you're just putting together people's
stories and music and clips bravo bravo
gentlemen